nineteen eighty five when I was five six
years old it wasn't even a choice
anymore I was a naturally born Bayern
fan and I've continued with that my
entire life
Naruto mental middle class I join it
there and since your place tighter sorry
Cara klavia see joaquín out all day
going so far this
you shouldn't laugh at such a meager
Lucinda Devon despido Jerusalem acha did
that already fighting national geo blue
sea dime algo más de una noite area
supposed asunto de ella no interesa
setting [ __ ] visual Vogel kisses Elena
legend precedes most aqui NOS vamos
mijos
sup I don't do them now with this one is
an army anyways have a teacher now
coaching now develop yourself so you I
use a coupon
that's a big guy there's big bad to the
big bully boy of the leg facing them is
done pretty much a satisfying as it can
get for adult man fat
these are the two best goal Gators in
the Buddha's League Robert Lepper dost
10 girls in one week pierre-emerick
aubameyang who has spotted all seven of
his first games
see we will start again
nah I in the fun zone is this real
getting that he went to a fondo de mundo
y 000 ha Myeong Ju girls feel for us hi
mom your fill of uniforms from the dog
ski he's in a pretty rare a patch of
form so he's got to be one of the danger
met no one like super milla milla is he
he's not the prettiest looking player in
terms how he plays but he can score a
goal at any moment from anywhere Marisa
Savoy you know he's on his chef Antenor
so good you know like a burger lucky
there so it's a kind of Paris abou good
e I'm positive about this kind of quite
hoping it doesn't matter usually even
went by and speed ten points ahead of
the league these games have been close
and we've done just as well we've won
just as many as we block
already the ball one there by Thomas
Muller it was caster that's the position
he likes to be in in the center its
Robert madoski away by Hummels and
there's a long sigh
genetic ozawa 10 Akasha
00 t psycho I work in government
relations essentially i'm a lobbyist
right now i work in lobby ously
insurance industry I grew up in northern
Bavaria and then I also spent a big part
of my life in fact oh it's no bother and
we always really loved Munich in Munich
is such a it's such a great German city
I spend so much time in my daily life at
work that I think in terms of my free
time soccer probably takes about ninety
percent my life when I see the amount of
Bayern fans gathered together I take
personal pride in that because it's such
a it's such a big deal for me you know
it's a little bit of my culture and
other people get to take part of that
saying that's another good ball it's a
copy
it's a lovely long ball
and thomas miller just stuck out at 0
with the right foods and with the left
managed to score
I yoga Santa what are you sure
Oh
what am I didn't ha ha ha those of a 30
50 states they could ask funny and
yourself but that is isomorphic to the
yellow hair Miami to the muffin
no Corrado a gym in checotah why yeah
photo album Oh F could even do anything
haha no not even
bugatti n quincy noho en su steady
rockin tomodachi Lumia kashikar autonomy
Torito a Cardassian a casa sin nadie te
toca imma cana y soy yo kudo moga equity
stead SI wey soy bueno un delito
fantastic reche mu chinita seven strike
for Millar now lil boy what a time food
the chest is all seen da Kommando atop
the hazardous areas on the bachelor
party unlock via twitter is a job
selling the aquarium to some realities
nope nah Vicki tai'an with the foul on
Tiago oh my goodness now all the referee
Marco freights have no other alternative
Claris and smita I'll take the penalty I
think the penalty
hungry hungry
ooh a true compassion ago she ran her
total indo-pakistani woman hope so 20yo
while attention sumanth edge which
holder ah tenzin samphel dr. ninguna
Kyla
they re-enter you Joe joining yet mahou
studio paper with an answer from a tin
can you ensure Tom Sirinoya repair watch
hindi songs to talk when George W Hotel
Hardwick Hall no Charlie ensign actually
get Ian Connelly is that shoe dyers I
don't play gin calendar so you're just
really cannot record evening that I say
you're almost unnatural yeah no yeah
wicket I annie has been lively
Oh
Oh
that is all ready now for album young
his tenth strike and he's scored in all
eight fixtures this season is a new
Bundesliga rock on
of course you know of course it was a
Boomer yang in the 36 he's always been
talking about how they gonna be buying
today that's what a noise in the most
because he's not nearly as good as he
thinks he is right going green 2
necessary for the temple certes go Longo
significance turned up in my anger NC go
for it providencia darte los codos Jill
a Kubrick door tomorrow Monsieur de
gestão voy a hacer una pues aqui me
deixa Feliciano asim Oh Mia he'll dodge
que ama saddaji fin integrant itachi
gusto discos y Paz comincia spesso
skeevy impresses sus Casas Ramos Adagio
hey Kenya and looking sooo de nada
Thomas Miller with two goals and over my
egg his tenth of the season as the
team's go into the dressing rooms with a
score by m2 Dortmund one
the mentalist anymore see that's Cara no
I rent aiji-ma segway board I'm awesome
to exist after Angela oh ok Jetta singer
sinatra bad support se da quella go
dopamine d serramonte geophys o segundo
tiempo mas agua de mesa boom day Omaha
animado no see me at my PO ceglia
assertive on kosovo's cohen patch Oh at
emerson verado segundo tema de Esperanza
Ocho mahi mahi
I think in the second half we have 11
dusty gore I think it's going to get 31
and we'll see where we go from there
shared in LA and by N word e Chidambaram
cassini Robert Lewandowski they went to
nil up which is pretty unusual usually
eight games quite Titan but I thought
the game was over then but we've got one
back and see how we go on the second up
I work for an aged care provider and I'm
also studying to be a paramedic the fans
are a big reason why i started supported
Brewster Dortmund
the first time I drop I set eyes on the
suit Tribune when I was you know 12
years old my mouth just dropped I
couldn't believe fans could create a
spectacle like that and that was really
what hooks me to be honest to borussia
dortmund in the first place welcome back
to the Allianz Arena here in Munich was
the adornment have already taken to the
field
see what happens in the second nom
I've got me a new one of our better
players just scored again I think that's
nine games in a row now eight games i
think it is eating it his own sake games
in a row that he's scored so the
meetings in fantastic form there's got
to go at it as if it's going for that I
see really just say that you short one
and live in dusty hazard pay no there's
no you can't make that stuff up mate
Jerome Boateng who set up the first goal
and he's looking for Lemon Robert
as if im sue cooper balls two magicians
hat miss convert AVI hot the film taken
acid do you remember to do your back
like a drink expenditures or just
definitely taking in cameras near jumble
of words jealous
when including miss Monica eponymous
tratar de van dos da sempre gracias
muchas balance average day Eve I'm
imagine celly a big rally gimme bra
mostly by Eric actually todo será yeah
buddy vandalism
what you guys say
11 dosti just keeps on story fire
extender lead to 31 vara no Thomas's my
da da favela menzie pata nahi taken
think dama me she'd vote arching
profession
Marco Royce and ABNA Jana's I enter the
fray house of yellow shirts in there and
that is Michael rice he couldn't get it
on target
my lord elsevier know everything good
recipe good job my schedule FCB recipe
goes 11 and 12
Roberts Levin go skate hey it's such a
difference to watch by on you want to
learn at home but you're not here and
this 105 times yes and the atmosphere
it's a good college center
say
Oh Scott who jack up a party dog water
for me thank God you fees
once again is turning into a spectacular
afternoon evening day's work for my
invention 51 up on borussia dortmund
but that's the way what do you mean we
do not get what's it
422 am
and we lost 5-4
the money horrendous
fantasmic stay hard to think of any
positive
pretty horrible
no more tedious to us unless you can go
where
is
we should round up Mexicans at the devil
this is ruben boy fell to her violent I
smaller panels for my babeh
I
five to one I mean I predict four three
two one I am more than excited I think
this may be decide to go to see a season
and although I'm excited about that I
would like Dortmund to be competitive
with us and so I hope they do well the
resin season for the fish young etosha
podria toma de hot Ally Pally dodge by
mais non desa form para las ocho gone
fish balls in Tagalog ama makan frattini
sada moohibah strange oshkosh enjoy
girl's attention poking my lord if you
were to say ouch
you
I money singing oh she got kids yoga
dance won't lock you up I hand up a book
she had some at him up there took this
she was the one who go
yep
hey
I